[Music]  Paula Patton wins temporary custody over  her son Julian according to court docs  obtained by ET patents x singer robin  thicke has been ordered to stay away  from her and their six-year-old son the  judge issued a temporary domestic  violence restraining order at paula's  request in the docs that actress accuses  the singer of drug use cheating and  physical abuse patent was granted  temporary legal and physical custody of  Julian Nick will have three monitoring  visits a week fix lawyer calls pads  accusations nothing more than a  retaliatory move since the singer  requested sole custody his lawyer  expects thick will be cleared of abuse  allegations reps for patent and thick  have no comment